[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: In this
video, we'll show you
how to predict images
using Vertex AI.
From Cloud Console,
go to Vertex AI.
Enable Vertex AI API.
Click Create Dataset.
Select Cloud Storage, and
specify the file path.
The file includes the
list of over 3,000 flowers
with their names.
Click Train New Model.
Specify AutoML and a budget
of 8 maximum node hours.
Start training.
Wait for about an hour.
Click Models.
Select the trained model.
Select Deploy and Test tab.
Click Deploy to Endpoint.
Specify endpoint name, and
allocate one node for it.
Click Deploy.
Now, open the
blank presentation.
Draw a flower, and create
its screenshot image.
Upload the image.
The image was
predicted as sunflower
with the confidence of 0.526.
That's it.
To learn more about Vertex
AI, look at the links
in the video description.
[MUSIC PLAYING]